the latest in the conga line of
coronavirus infections can it connected
to the white house
is donald trump's own press secretary
kaylee mckennany
we just saw a video of rudy giuliani
unable to stop
coughing during a fox news interview he
is waiting on his latest test results
for coronavirus
we may have gotten those results by the
time you watch that clip or this clip
but someone who did test positive is
white house press secretary
kelly mcinanny and two of her deputies
have tested positive for the coronavirus
as well
as donald trump has now left walter reed
medical center
presumably still contagious first lady
melania trump
remains in isolation with coronavirus
she reportedly doesn't want to spread it
to the secret service agents who she
would be exposing if she were to try to
go
anywhere kaylee mcinanny putting out a
statement
via twitter which says quote after
testing
negative consistently including every
day since thursday it's funny how they
always say that like listen
everybody who gets coronavirus tests
would have tested negative for a long
time
until they test positive okay after
testing negative consistently
including every day since thursday i
tested positive for covet 19 on monday
morning
while experiencing no symptoms no
reporters producers or members of the
press are listed as close contacts by
the white house medical unit
moreover i definitely i definitively had
no knowledge of hope hicks's diagnosis
prior to holding a white house press
briefing on thursday
as an essential worker i have worked
diligently to provide
needed information to the american
people at this time
that's funny the idea that her lies are
essential
with my recent positive tests i will
begin the quarantine
process and will continue working on
behalf of the american people remotely
now this is a picture of her just days
ago
briefing a gaggle of reporters without a
mask on
and it simply continues to spread at the
white house
she was criticized for briefing
reporters without a mask
hours after donald trump tested positive
the defenders came out and said they
were socially distant she was she took
the mask off only when she was
uh not near reporters well for the
entire week during which she was likely
contagious or part of that week
she wasn't wearing a mask at all the
mask
started later on in the week we of
course have
numerous others connected to trump who
have tested positive at this point it's
hard to even keep track but it includes
trump's own campaign manager bill
stephen republican national committee
chairwoman rana mcdaniel
trump advisor kellyanne conway and
kellyanne conway's daughter claudia
conway have tested positive
new jersey governor chris christie
tested positive three republican
senators i mentioned yesterday mike lee
of utah
tom tillis of north carolina who's up
against it he may be about to get
beaten badly by cal cunningham in north
carolina
uh wisconsin republican ron johnson nick
luna who's a personal assistant to
donald trump
the university of notre dame president
john jenkins tested positive he was at
the amy coney barrett event
not this past saturday but the previous
one at the white house which does appear
to be
a super spreader event at least three
journalists who were at the white house
over the last week have now tested
positive
according to the white house
correspondents association
remember when kaylee mcinanni said
on fox news back in february the
following
absolutely this president will always
put america first he will always protect
american citizens we will not see
diseases like the coronavirus come here
we will not see terrorism come here and
isn't that refreshing
when contrasting it with the awful
presidency of president obama kaylee
mcanammy thank you so much good to see
you
thank you so that was a ridiculous thing
to say
then and it's even more ridiculous to
say it
now that donald trump has it and she now
has tested positive
it is the fascinatingly dystopian
secondary story so you've got how has
this administration handled coronavirus
that's a primary story
it's immoral it's disgusting and it's
infuriating
how they handle it when they themselves
get the virus
is arguably more absurd although not
connected to as many deaths
because remember that this either began
or was exacerbated by a party in the
rose garden
as well as inside the white house where
hundreds of people sat shoulder to
shoulder without masks
hugging talking inches from each other's
faces kaylee
along with numerous other people like
william barr
have continued to make public
appearances with no masks
knowing they were exposed to people that
tested positive no contact tracing
has been done we learned that joe
biden's campaign was not contacted as
people started testing positive
including trump to say hey
this happened isolate test quarantine
whatever you need to do
they've been deceptive about the
timelines it has been asked now
nearly a dozen times when did donald
trump last test negative
they won't tell us directly implying
that trump either knew or suspected he
was contagious during the debate with
joe biden
that their claim on the honor system
that biden
rather that trump tested negative on the
day of the debate he probably wasn't
tested at all
and so aside from never doing that crazy
amy coney barrett event at the white
house
everybody here involved should have
immediately
self-isolated for 14 days when hope
hicks got sick
that alone would have reduced the
transmission but they either don't care
or are unwilling to do the right thing
for other people it is stunning
they deserve a historic loss in november
not only
for their personal irresponsibility as
leaders but because they've overseen
one of the worst responses in the world
to the virus which is now surging again
in many states one of our sponsors today
is vincero watches and they're giving
you up to 30 percent off
everything in their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch if you're looking for an awesome
way to
update your look the perfect way to do
it is with an elegant
high quality wrist watch when there's a
company like vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company
that's made it possible to own an
excellent watch
without breaking the bank all of their
watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video